do you really think Epstein killed
himself
it's funny cuz this is one of those
things you know if whatever I say it's a
lose right yeah but a man there's a lot
of coincidence there yeah you know what
I've seen you know I'm not gonna say yes
or no but you know a guy who's there
he's magically then you know within
hours of being you know off of suicide
watch the two cameras that are on him
happened to go out the two guards just
happen man it seems like a lot of
coincidence you know that they try to
make Epstein you know they tried to make
it about Trump they don't talk about
like the forty five times you know
Clinton's at the island with him with
Bill you know they say well he meant
Trump at a cocktail party one time look
we got you I'm like literally he was
literally thrown out of mar-a-lago
because you know some of the rumors and
all this stuff so you know and that's
the problem the news cycle whether it's
that whether it's you know Ukraine like
I've been talking like go look at my
stump speech it's like I've been talking
about Ukraine and the corruption there
and all that nonsense for like a year
you know when it got mainstream media
pick up when they could make it about
Trump
you know Epstein it's been a problem for
a long time this has been like a de
facto thing whether you know Matt Lauer
and NBC all these things are to get
they've been in the room when you can
somehow try to make it about Trump or
when they're no longer in power to be
able to do do your bidding you know
that's that's when it becomes news and
so you know they don't talk about those
things they only become news when you
can somehow use it as a way to own Trump
and we got them and so you know it's a
problem one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the SiriusXM app